herr Präsident
meine Damen und Herren passt auf den
Tag heute vor 50 Jahren hatten zwei
deutsche Staaten den Vereinten Nationen
bei
als 133 Mitglied die damalige Deutsche
Demokratische Republik als Mitglied
Nummer 134 die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland
dieser Schritt hat für uns Deutsche bis
heute große Bedeutung
denn mit der Mitgliedschaft in den
Vereinten Nationen war für mein Land
Urheber furchtbar Kriege und grausamer
Verbrechen die Möglichkeit verbunden
zurückzukehren in die Familie
friedliebender Völker
für diese Chance sind wir zutiefst
dankbar
die Rückkehr war nicht frei von
Voraussetzung
vorausgegangen war dem deutschen
Beitritt eine visionäre Politik der
Entspannung sie folgte dem Ziel die
Gräben des Kalten Krieges zuzuschütten
wie mein Vorgänger Bundeskanzler und
Friedensnobelpreisträger Willy Brandt es
vor 50 Jahren hier in New York
formulierte
drei Dinge waren dafür unerlässlich
erstens das klare Bekenntnis bei der
deutscher Staaten Konflikte ohne Gewalt
zu lösen
niedergelegt wurde das im
Grundlagenvertrag zwischen Bonn und
Ostberlin sowie in den Verträgen die die
Bundesrepublik mit ihren östlichen
Nachbarn Schloss
die zweite Voraussetzung war der
Verzicht auf jegliche Form des
Revisionismus in dem die nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg neu entstandenen
Grenzen Deutschlands als unverletzlich
anerkannt wurden
diese Entscheidung steht damals bei
vielen Bürgern und Bürgern
Westdeutschlands auf Ablehnung im
Rückblick hat sie sich als richtig
erwiesen
die dritte Voraussetzung war schließlich
eine Politik die die Realität des Kalten
Krieges nicht ausblendet und die
zugleich immer darauf gerichtet blieb
den Status Quo also die Konfrontation
der Blöcke und damit auch die
unnatürliche Teilung Deutschlands zu
überwinden
wenn ich hier und heute auf diese
Anfänger unserer Mitgliedschaft in den
Vereinten Nationen zurückblicke dann
nicht nur aus historischen Interesse
sondern weil das Gewaltverbot immer noch
das unerreichte kernversprechen unser
Vereinten Nationen bildet
weil die unverletzbarkeit von Grenzen
und die souveräne Gleichheit der Staaten
auch in unserer multipolaren Welt
verteidigt werden muss und zwar von uns
allen
und weil wir auch heute gerade heute den
Mut die Kreativität und den Willen
brauchen Gräben zu überwinden
Gräben die sich tiefer auftun denn je
diesen drei idealen dem Verzicht auf
Gewalt als Mittel der Politik der
Ablehnung jeglicher Form des
Revisionismus und dem Bekenntnis zur
Zusammenarbeit über Trennendes hinweg
fühlt Deutschland sich zutiefst
verpflichtet
uns Deutschen haben diese Ideale das
große Glück beschert heute in einem
vereinten Land zu leben in Frieden mit
unseren Nachbarn mit Freunden und
Partnern auf der ganzen Welt
und zugleich gilt heute umso mehr das
was wir die Brandt hier bereits vor 50
Jahren sagte
in einer Welt in der zunehmend jeder von
jedem abhängt da Friedenspolitik nicht
vor der eigenen Haustür halt machen
deutsche Politik kann und wird sich nie
darin erschöpfen ohne Rücksicht auf
andere unsere Interessen durchzusetzen
weil wir wissen unsere Freiheit unsere
Demokratie und unser Wohlstand sind
zutiefst mit dem Wohlergehen Europas und
der Welt verknüpft
deshalb lautet das Gebot der Stunde auch
nicht weniger Kooperationen als heute
heute
vielleicht als die kapling oder als
Zusammenarbeit nur unter Gleichgesinnten
verpackt sondern mehr Kooperation die
Stärkung bestehende Allianzen genauso
wie die Suche nach neuen Partnern denn
nur so lassen sich auch die Risiken
allzu einseitige Abhängigkeiten abbauen
das gilt umso mehr in einer Welt die
anders als vor 50 Jahren nicht mehr nur
zwei Machtzentren kennt sondern viele
unterschiedliche
Multipolarität ist keine neue Ordnung
wer damit verbindet das kleinere Länder
der Hinterhof größerer Länder sind der
irrt
Multipolarität ist keine normative
Kategorie sondern eine
Zustandsbeschreibung
wenn einer multipolaren Welt nach
Ordnung sucht der muss hier bei den
Vereinten Nationen beginnen
deshalb unterstützt Deutschland das
UN-System und leistet als zweitgrößter
Geber nach den Vereinigten Staaten aus
voller Überzeugung seinen Beitrag
nur die Vereinten Nationen auf Basis der
Werte die in ihrer Kater verkörpert sind
lösen den Anspruch universeller
Repräsentanz und souveränergleichheit
aller vollumfänglich ein
das gilt weder für die G7 oder die G20
so wichtig sie für die weltweite
Abstimmung sind noch für die bricks oder
andere Gruppen
ich weiß was manche dem entgegenhalten
sind die Vereinten Nationen nicht allzu
oft handlungsunfähig gelähmt von den
Antagonismen ihrer heterogenen
Mitgliedschaft
denjenigen sage ich die Blockade einiger
weniger und seien sie noch so
einflussreich darf uns doch nicht
darüber hinwegtäuschen dass wir die ganz
große Mehrheit der Staaten uns in vielem
einig sind wir alle fast alle wollen das
Gewalt als Mittel der Politik geächtet
bleibt
wir alle haben ein Interesse daran dass
die Souveränität die territoriale
unversehrt hat und die politische
Unabhängigkeit unserer Länder geachtet
wird
und wir alle sollten wissen was dies
voraussetzt nämlich dass wir diese
Rechte auch anderen zugestehen
diese goldenen Regeln sind universell
auch wenn viele von uns noch nicht mit
am Tisch saßen als unkrater 1945
verabschiedet wurde
doch schon zehn Jahre später im
indonesischen Wandung waren es die vom
kolleginismus befreiten Staaten Afrikas
und Asiens die ihre Stimme für
Selbstbestimmung für territoriale
Unversehrtheit für souveräne Gleichheit
aller Staaten und für eine Welt ohne
Kolonialismus und Imperialismus erhoben
dies scheint heute aktueller denn je
an diesem Prinzipien müssen wir alle ob
groß oder klein uns messen lassen diese
Prinzipien müssen auch bei der
Neuordnung unser multipolaren Welt die
Grundlage bilden
nur dann lassen sich auch die globalen
Herausforderungen unserer Zeit lösen
die größte davon ist der
menschengemachte Klimawandel
natürlich tragen die klassischen
Industrieländern beim Kampf gegen die
Klimakrise ganz besondere Verantwortung
zugleich gehören heute viele weitere
Länder zu den größten Emittenten
statt nun auf andere zu warten müssen
wir alle gemeinsam mehr tun für die
Erreichung der Pariser Klimaziele
jede und jeder Einzelne von ihnen muss
die Chance erhalten das gleiche Maß an
Wohlstand zu erlangen wie die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in Europa
Nordamerika oder Ländern wie Japan oder
Australien
doch wenn sich diese wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung mit den Technologien und
Produktionsweisen des 19 oder 20
Jahrhunderts vollzieht mit
verbrennermotoren und Kohlekraftwerken
dann wird unser Planet das nicht
überstehen
daraus folgt doch eines wir müssen
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung entkoppeln
vom Ausstoß von CO2
in vielen Ländern gelingt das bereits
denn die Lösungsansätze und Technologien
dafür haben wir
als starkes Technologie anbieten wir an
hier zum gemeinsam wohl zusammen zu
arbeiten
wenn Produzenten erneuerbarer Energien
und deren industrielle Nutzer über
Kontinente hinweg zusammenfinden
schaffen wir gemeinsam neuen Wohlstand
an vielen Orten dieser Welt
und ich bin froh ihn heute ankündigen zu
können Deutschland erfüllt auch seine
Zusagen zur internationalen
Klimafinanzierung
von zwei Milliarden Euro im Jahr 2014
über 4 Milliarden Euro im Jahr 22 haben
wir unseren Beitrag im letzten Jahr auf
6 Milliarden Euro verdreifacht
damit halten wir Wort
das tun auch die industrie-länder
insgesamt die dieses Jahr wohl erstmals
von 100 Milliarden Euro für die
internationale Klimafinanzierung erfüllt
werden
das ist ein wichtiges Signal ein
überfälliges Signal bevor wir im
Dezember in Dubai Bilanz ziehen und über
neue klimaschutzpläne ab 2030 verhandeln
mir ist wichtig dass wir dabei so
konkret und so verbindlich wie möglich
sind deshalb werbe ich dafür dass wir
uns in Dubai klare Ziele für den Ausbau
der erneuerbaren Energien und für mehr
Energieeffizienz setzen
genauso ambitioniert werden wir bei der
Erreichung der sdgs der nachhaltigen
Entwicklungsziele sein
Klimaschutz oder Entwicklung diese
Abwägung geht nicht auf
unser Gipfel gestern hat mir gezeigt wie
dringend wie auch bei den sdgs aufholen
müssen
deshalb wollen wir beim summit of the
future im kommenden Jahr den wir
gemeinsam mit unseren Freunden aus
Namibia vorbereiten weiter Tempo machen
und die Umsetzung der Agenda 2030
vorantreiben
wichtig ist mir in diesem Kontext dass
wir für mehr private Investitionen in
Afrika Asien Lateinamerika und der
Karibik sorgen so ein Beispiel
die ganze Welt redet derzeit über die
Diversifizierung von Lieferketten und
über rohstoffsicherheit wäre es da nicht
ein Anfang das wenigstens der erste
Verarbeitungsschritt vor Ort stattfindet
dort wo die Rohstoffe im Boden liegen
Deutschland und die deutsche Wirtschaft
jedenfalls sind offen dafür genau solche
Partnerschaften einzugehen
wir alle stehen in den kommenden Jahren
natürlich vor der Herausforderung unsere
Wirtschaft unsere Energieversorgung und
unsere Infrastruktur in eine Ressourcen
schonende klimaneutrale Zukunft zu
führen
das bedarf hoher Investitionen
damit diese Investitionen gestemmt
werden können
müssen wir die Schuldenkrise vieler
Länder adressieren und die
internationale Finanzarchitektur
modernisieren
ich habe es eingangs gesagt
Deutschland lebt nicht im Status Quo
auch in dieser Frage nicht wir wollen
dass sich etwas ändert ich setze mich
dafür ein
zuletzt beim G20-Gipfel in die dass sich
die multilateralen Entwicklungsbanken
reformieren
damit sie mehr zur Finanzierung von
globalen öffentlichen Gütern wie dem
Schutz von Klima und Biodiversität oder
der Prävention von Pandemien beitragen
können
so haben es die G20 auch in Deli
beschlossen
Deutschland unterstützt dieser Reformen
auch finanziell
als erstes Land investieren wir 35
Millionen Euro Hybridkapital in die
Weltbank Kapital mit dem die Weltbank
laut den Erwartungen mehr als zwei
Milliarden Euro an zusätzlichen Krediten
vergeben kann
meine Damen und Herren
Generalsekretär gute Rest hat heute
morgen auf die rasant steigenden
humanitären Bedarfe angesichts der
vielen Krisen weltweit hingewiesen
deutschland ist der zweitgrößte geh bei
humanitärer Hilfe weltweit und wir
werden auch weiter an der Seite der
Menschen in größter Not steht
auch unsere Vereinten Nationen selbst
dürfen nicht am Status quo kleben meine
Damen und Herren und man damit meine ich
zweierlei erstens die Vereinten Nationen
müssen sich den Herausforderungen der
Zukunft zusenden so wie auch
Generalsekretär Antonio guter Letzt das
vorstellt
eine der ganz großen Fragen ist da wir
aus meiner Sicht wie wir Innovationen
und technologischen Fortschritt für die
ganze Menschheit nutzbar machen können
künstliche Intelligenz etwa bringt große
Chancen und zugleich kann sie die
Spaltung der Welt zementieren wenn nur
einige davon profitieren wenn
Algorithmen nur ein Teil der Realität
berücksichtigen wenn der Zugang auf die
reicheren Länder beschränkt ist
deshalb fördert Deutschland mit
Nachdruck den Austausch zum
global-dicket will compact
dabei sollten wir auch über gemeinsame
Regeln für den möglichen Einsatz
generativer künstlicher Intelligenz als
Waffe sprechen
eine weitere Zukunftsfrage ist wie die
Feinden Nationen selbst die Realität
einer multipolaren Welt abbilden
bisher tun sie das nicht ausreichend
nirgendwo ist das so augenfällig wie bei
der Zusammensetzung des Sicherheitsrats
deshalb freue ich mich dass immer mehr
Partner darunter drei der ständigen
Mitglieder erklärt haben in der
reformfrage Vorankommen zu wollen
klar ist doch Afrika gebührt mir Gewicht
so wie auch Asien und Lateinamerika
unter dieser Prämisse lässt sich über
einen Text mit verschiedenen Optionen
verhandeln
solche Ergebnisse oft in Verhandlungen
sollte kein Land mit Maximalforderungen
blockieren auch wir tun das nicht
letztlich liegt es in der Hand der
Generalversammlung über eine Reform des
Sicherheitsrates zu entscheiden
bis dann möchte Deutschland als nicht
ständiges Mitglied des
UN-Sicherheitsrates Verantwortung
übernehmen und ich bitte Sie unsere
Kandidatur für die Jahre
2027/28 zu unterstützen
meine Damen und Herren wenn ich in
diesen Tagen und vor dieser Versammlung
vom Frieden rede dann sind meine
Gedanken bei denjenigen für die Frieden
ein ferner Traum ist
bei den sudanesinnen und Sudanesen die
Opfer eines grausam Machtkampfes
zwischen zwei Kriegsherren geworden sind
bei den Frauen und Männern im Osten
Kongos oder ganz aktuell an die Menschen
in Karabach die erneuten militärischen
Aktivitäten davon bin ich überzeugt
führen in die Sackgasse sie müssen
Enten und natürlich bei den ukraineren
und Ukrainern die um ihr Leben und ihre
Freiheit kämpfen um die Unabhängigkeit
und die territoriale Integrität ihres
Landes
um die Wahrung genau der Prinzipien den
wir uns alle in der verpflichtet haben
doch nicht nur die Ukraine stürzt
Russlands Angriffskrieg in großes Leid
unter Inflation wachsender Verschuldung
Düngemittel Knappheit Hunger und
steigender Armut leiden Bürgern und
Bürger weltweit gerade weil dieser Krieg
unerträgliche Folgen rund um den Globus
hat ist es gut und richtig dass sich die
Welt auch an der Suche nach Frieden
beteiligt
und zugleich müssen wir uns vor
Scheinlösung hüten die Frieden lediglich
im Namen tragen
denn Frieden ohne Freiheit heißt
Unterdrückung
Frieden ohne Gerechtigkeit nennt man
Diktat
das muss nun endlich auch Moskau
verstanden
denn vergessen wir nicht Russland ist
für diesen Krieg verantwortlich und es
ist russlands Präsident die mit einem
einzigen Befehl jederzeit beenden kann
doch damit er das tut muss er verstehen
dass wir die Staaten der Vereinten
Nationen es ernst meinen mit unseren
Prinzipien dass wir in der multipolaren
Welt des 21 jahrhunderts keinen Platz
mehr sehen für Revisionismus und
Imperialismus
kaum jemand hat das hier in New York so
treffen formuliert wie unser Kollege der
Botschafter Kenias
nach Russlands Einmarsch in die Ukraine
hatte im Sicherheitsrat folgendes gesagt
Brother than from nations that looked in
history with the dangerous nostalgia we
choose to look forward greatness
Germanys history hols many lessons about
the danger
different Park when we joint the United
Nations fifty years
of peace and we conciliation the passing
existing borders the pass of Corporation
wird all of you in the pursuit of the
better
it started Salem promise that we made
fifty years
everyone of using United Nations
international peace and security
letters all do a best to live up to that
promise
vielen Dank
guten